-Our next guest is an Emmy
and Peabody-winning
writer and producer
whose work, you know,
from shows like "Inside Amy
Schumer," "Big Mouth,"
And "I Love That for You."
Her best-selling book,
"I'll Show Myself Out: Essays
on Midlife and Motherhood,"
is out now in paperback.
Please welcome back to the show
Jessi Klein, everybody.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome back, Jessi.
-Thank you.
-We were talking backstage
the last time you were here
was a live show.
-Yes.
-We were on late at night
in 2016, the evening
that Hillary Clinton
accepted the Democratic
nomination for president.
-Yeah.
-And pretty much all we talked
about were how many balloons
dropped from the ceiling.
-There were so many balloons.
We talked about
just how excited and happy
we were that everything
was about to be perfect.
-Yeah.
-We didn't realize the
trajectory of the balloons
was downward.
-Was down through the floor
into full hell. Yeah.
That they were lead balloons.
-They were lead balloons,
it turns out.
-Yeah.
-This is a wonderful book
of essays, which we when it
first came out,
we talked about it a little bit.
We were writers together at
"SNL."
And you're very honest
about a step you took
to sort of deal with the stress
and pressure of the table
read on Wednesday.
-Yes.
-And it was lovely to read it
because it was a reminder
that there's just no way
to make it easier.
-Well, you're being very kind,
Seth,
because what people here
don't know is
that I just bombed the whole
year that I wrote for "SNL,"
and it's a very stressful table
read and everyone's there,
and I was trying to figure out
what could I do
to make up for my lack of talent
in writing on this show?
And I decided the thing to do
was to get a lot of, like,
good luck jewelry
that had, like, inspirational
things engraved on it
because that would project
a lot of confidence.
[ Laughter ]
And so I remember
I bought a necklace
that said "fearlessness" on it
because I'm like,
if people see that, they won't
realize these sketches suck.
[ Laughter ]
And then I bought on Etsy,
which is a great website
for engravable
inspirational jewelry,
I bought a ring that said --
it said on the inside,
"This too shall pass."
-Okay.
-And so I would be
in that table read
waiting for my sketches
to be horribly over
and just be like, "This too,
the sketch too shall pass."
And then they would,
into oblivion.
-In the end, do you feel like it
was worth -- the money
was worth it on
the inspirational jewelry?
-Absolutely not.
A full waste.
Yeah. Money into the garbage.
-Yeah.
-"Edible Boyfriend," right?
-Wait, what?
-"Edible Boyfriend" was
a Jessi Klein sketch.
-Oh, yeah. I was like -- Yes.
-That is a crazy thing
to just say out of nowhere.
I do apologize
for no context.
-I had a moment of, like,
needing out of the car.
-"Edible Boyfriend" and you're
like, "Wait, is that a story
I'm supposed to tell?"
Now, you had a boyfriend once
you ate, right?
-Yes, I just finished
eating my boyfriend.
I'm like, "This appearance
went so well."
-I hope my memory's right.
Yes?
-Well, I think the confusion
and the reason
I just got whiplash
was it was called
"Brownie Husband."
-Okay. Gotcha.
[ Laughter ]
-But it could have been called
and should have been called
"Edible Boyfriend."
-I will say
as a talk show host,
I have done you no favors.
-No, no, no.
You are doing me the
opposite of dirty.
-Alright. Thanks.
-Yeah.
-I sent one of your essays
to my wife,
who then, over the course
of the next week --
-Edible wife.
-Yeah, my edible wife.
-She used to be
my brownie girlfriend.
I made her an honest edible.
-An honest edible.
-But she, you know,
she said that in the course
of the week that followed,
she said like eight other moms
had sent it to her.
-Yeah.
-And I feel like you must be
getting feedback like that.
-Yeah. It was really nice.
Yeah, the first chapter
in the book kind of went viral.
It was like published
in "New York Magazine,"
and I just started
getting a lot of
like -- a lot of women
sliding into my DMs,
which is really what you
want, a lot of moms,
but just saying like,
"I feel seen,
thank you for writing this."
And then there was sometimes
just a level of like
sort of desperation
that you would feel of like,
"I have like three kids
under the age of five and, like,
I'm at the bottom
of the ocean, no one's slept."
And you're like,
"Maybe you should call 911."
-Yeah.
-Instead of DMing me.
But I was very grateful.
It was really nice.
-I should note one of
the important things to say
about this book
is it's wildly funny,
and one of the things
I've heard you say is like,
it's really hard.
You don't really want
to hear about people --
how great people's kids are,
but it's super fun to hear
that other people's kids
are pains in the asses.
-Oh, all I want to do
is hear about what turds
other people's kids are.
Yeah, there's nothing worse
than, like,
someone else's, like, polite,
well-behaved kid
who eats everything
they're supposed to do.
Like, I remember when my kid
first started
going to preschool,
I would see what other kids
had in their lunch boxes
because, like,
my kid's still --
He's almost eight and he only
eats, like, bread and cheese,
which is, of course, what we all
want to eat and what I eat now
because I'm an adult
and I can do whatever I want.
But there was like those kids
who have those
little bento boxes.
Like, there was -- I remember
a kid who had just
cherry tomatoes,
raw cherry tomatoes,
in one of the sections.
I saw this kid
eat the cherry tomato,
and I was like,
"I have to go punch a wall."
I'm so -- How dare you?
How dare you? All of you.
-So, I actually have met
this person as well.
I don't know
if it's the same person,
but you write an essay
about the car seat lady,
which I think might --
some people
might not believe
is a real thing.
-Yeah, she's real.
And I bet it probably
is the same car seat lady.
-I think so, too.
I feel like she may be,
like, just, you know,
copyrighted the name.
-Yeah. There's --
When you have a child,
by law, you have to put them
into a car seat.
-Yeah.
-To keep them safe.
Unlike when we were kids
and you would just, like,
rattle around in the back of
whatever.
But yeah,
there's a car seat lady.
You hear about her through,
like, word of mouth.
Sort of like a drug dealer.
And then she -- You meet her
on a corner.
-For real you do.
-You meet her on a corner.
-You bring a car
and a car seat.
-You bring a car and a car seat
and you meet her on a corner
and she's just like,
"You want a car seat?"
Because they're
very hard to install.
-It's the dumbest thing
in the world.
And it's very exacting
how you have to do it
or at least she makes you
feel --
I mean, if she's watching,
thank you for your service.
-Oh, my God.
I want to make it
very clear as well.
Yes. Once she left,
I was like,
thank God,
we have avoided disaster.
-Yeah, we've avoided disaster.
But she's like,
"If you have this,"
I mean, it's
a five-point harness.
-Yeah.
-And if she's like,
"If you have it a centimeter up
or a centimeter down
in the wrong place,
like, you might as well
just throw your kid
into the trash."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, that's it. Yeah.
And I did meet one
at a parenting class.
I remember I met this dad
who also had had
the same car seat lady
and we were talking about how
bad she makes us feel
about what happens
if we F it up.
And he was saying that when
she was installing his car seat,
she was like,
"What's this on the floor?"
And he had a loose
meat cleaver...
[ Laughter ]
...that had fallen out of like
a West Elm box of knives
he'd bought and he never knew
where it went.
So he was the dad who just
had, like, a giant knife.
Yeah. I was like,
"At least I'm not that guy."
-She's like, "This probably goes
without saying,
but you don't want
a knife back here."
-Yeah, Yeah.
-"I'm just a car seat lady."
-"You might want to --"
Yeah.
Maybe don't have your kid...
At least we're not that.
-We're not that.
Neither of us had a knife there.
-Hey, I think we're doing great.
-I think we're doing great.
-Yeah.
-The book's fantastic.
It's so lovely to see you.
You guys, that's Jessi Klein.
"I'll Show Myself Out: Essays
on Midlife and Motherhood"
is very funny. It's on paperback
right now.
We'll be back with more
"Late Night."